[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonjour et bienvenue sur tv soixante dix
huit pour cette nouvelle édition du 7 8
week end avec aujourd'hui et grégory
canal et mélanie poquet bonjour à tous
les deux et j'ai revu en plateau nous
allons revenir ensemble sur l'actualité
de cette semaine mais aussi sur vos
loisirs avec une sélection à suivre elle
sera signée matt hill de franck ou qui
nous rejoindra également regardons plus
en détail le programme a pour
aujourd'hui la cité éducative cité de
l'emploi pas une semaine ne se passe
dans les yvelines sans qu'un nouveau
label ne soient décernés c'était encore
le cas ces derniers jours à quoi servent
ces appellations c'est ce que nous
verrons la campagne présidentielle se
poursuit dans le département michel
barnier ancien candidat à la primaire de
la droite aujourd'hui conseiller spécial
de valérie pécresse est venue tenir
meeting entretien à suivre versailles
c'est royal c'était là une de nos
confrères de l'équipe cette semaine
après la victoire du club de football de
national 2 face à toulouse club de ligue
2 en coupe de france retour sur cette
performance et sur les chances des
yvelinois pour les prochains tours et
puis du sport également avec les jeux
olympiques d'hiver qui débutent eux nous
parlerons de l'ancien cycliste 110k 110
claire qui a longtemps restés dans les
yvelines elle s'est envolé pour la chine
pour participer cette fois ci à des
épreuves de bobsleigh voilà pour le
programme pour débuter je vous propose
un tour d'horizon rapide 78 secondes une
minute 18 secondes pas une de plus pour
un résumé est complet des événements
marquants de la semaine c'est avec
justin brasier
la circulation épidémique en baisse en
ile-de-france conséquence un protocole
sanitaire allégée par le gouvernement
fin de l'obligation du port du masque en
extérieur ou encore faim des jauges pour
les établissements recevant du public
assis le programme c'était de l'emploi
de saint quentin en yvelines a été
officiellement lancée le but renforcer
l'accès à l'emploi et à la formation aux
habitants des quartiers prioritaires
objectif mieux coordonner les
dispositifs déjà présents sur le
territoire côté sport après sa victoire
contre toulouse 2 le fc versailles à
contre à bergerac en quart de finale de
coupe de france un record historique
pour le club amateur versailles et le
match se déroulera à périgueux coup
d'envoi mercredi 9 février à 18h30 la
facture s'alourdit pour le projet eole
1,7 milliard d'euros supplémentaires
nécessaires au prolongement du rer e
dont les yvelines une enquête a été
ouverte par le conseil régional
d'ile-de-france en politique jordan par
dell a été mis en examen le député
européen pour le rassemblement national
avait qualifié la ville de trappes de
république islamique des propos tenus en
octobre dernier suite à la réélection du
maire à lire à b et puis elle met à
l'honneur la ville des impressionnistes
de fresques réalisées à chatou cet été
ont été présélectionnés pour les golden
street art lancé par trompe-l'oeil info
le concours récompense les plus belles
presque de france
[Musique]
et
s'il ne fallait retenir qu'une seule
information cette semaine c'est très
subjectif comme choix je vous la corde
mélanie votre information de la semaine
vous me prenez oui
yvelinoise va peut-être moins les cités
parce que j'y suis allé j'ai fait la
cité de la jeunesse où j'ai pu
rencontrer des éducateurs sont
intéressants et
subjective puisque pour nous ce sera le
football grec absolument voilà fou cette
victoire donc de versailles face à
toulouse club de ligue 2 l'équipe
lilloise qui évolue d'habitude donc en
nationale 2 va pouvoir jouer pour
décrocher une place en demies et ce ne
sera pas face au paris saint germain a
éliminé par nice en 8e de finale c'est
injuste et c'était la petite bon pardon
pour les supporters parisiens mais c'est
l'affiché rêvée par les versaillais 1 pg
versailles pour ces quarts de finale pas
de marseille pas de nantes ou même
monaco versailles affrontera bergerac en
quarts de finale l'autre représentant de
nationale 2 c'est la 4e division
française est forcément un peu de
déception chez les versaillais au moment
du tirage au sort c'était lundi dernier
au delà de jouer de l'argent qu'on est
surtout triste de départ où souvent pour
notre public ça reste un match de coupe
quand même mais c'est surtout une place
qui joue en cours la demi finale et on
va te donner de façon on se dit que tout
est possible pour aller en demi finale
ça nous laisse une chance d'aider passer
en demi finales même si c'est une équipe
très sérieuse et contre laquelle on va
jouer chez eux sur leur terrain ça va
être un peu compliqué mais on va se
donner les moyens de passer deux jours
plus tôt versailles marqué l'histoire du
département pour la première fois un
club des yvelines or paris saint-germain
bien sûr accède aux quarts de finale de
la coupe de france et ce grâce à un
exploit une victoire au tour précédent 1
à 0 contre toulouse une équipe
professionnelle leader de la ligue 2 le
petit poucet qui bat le gros c'est en
somme toute la magie de cette
compétition seule mauvaise nouvelle au
tableau wilfried l'expulsion de mme
elvira en fin de match qui le privera de
cette carte de ce quart de finale et
c'est un exploit qui a fait le tour des
médias et qui a permis de laisser la
victoire du psg 2 côtés on n'a parlé que
de versailles s'est très bien réalisées
dans les titres versailles c'est royal
c'est le titre qu'a choisi l'équipe pour
ça une alternative au lendemain de cet
exploit car ce qui a marqué au delà de
la performance c'est la capacité des 10
millions à faire jeu égal avec leurs
adversaires
la différence de jeu ne s'est pas vu sur
le terrain comme l'expliqué jean luc
arribart c'est un ancien joueur
professionnel consultant chez canal + et
il est depuis octobre le directeur
général du club versailles je suis très
fier des joueurs je suis très fier du
résultat et j'avoue qu'ils m'ont épaté
par ce que je pense qu'ils ont fait un
match
le match plein le match avec beaucoup de
sérénité de conviction et puis et puis
je trouve qu'on a rivalisé sur le plan
tactique sur le plan technique aussi
dans l'engagement physique on a été
présents même peut-être un peu plus que
encore le but la conception du but est
remarquable c'est un but si c'est
manchester city qui marque selon lui on
le voit en boucle pendant pendant trois
semaines un homme aussi forcément
heureux c'est le maire de versailles on
n'a pas l'occasion de l'entendre souvent
sur le football il avait fait aussi le
déplacement à toulouse on est 13e on est
très fiers aussi pour l'équipe du coup
de club de versailles c'est une aventure
incroyable poivre et
toulouse et puis on sentait bien pendant
le match que finalement l'équipe avait
les boas être pas ça une équipe de
l'élite 2 que c'était tout à fait la
hauteur et puis à le but en deuxième mi
temps on est là c'est vraiment la grande
libération de joie et malgré tout les
versaillais sont revenus dans un quasi
anonymat il faut avouer que l'exploit
n'a pas créé un certain engouement dans
la cité royale qui est peu connue pour
être une ville de football ça peut
changer dans les prochaines années car
j'ai moi j'ai hâte de voir le maire et
jean pas de manière qu'on vient de voir
célébrer la victoire de la coupe de
france et la brandir tels jacques chirac
maintenant nous verrons peut-être de
l'île de versailles la wii est une ces
constructions inciter les joueurs de
l'équipe de france au moment de
l'annoncé de fiat de voir ça
on pourrait voir dans de prochaines
années versailles devenir une ville de
football parce qu'il faut rappeler qu'il
ya de grandes ambitions à la tête du
club via de nouveaux investisseurs qui
sont arrivés on a aussi quand même
trouvé quelques supporters dans les rues
de versailles moi je trouve ça génial ce
que c'est je crois que c'est l'un des
deux clubs encore amateur dans cette
coupe de france j'espère qu'ils vont
aller plus loin possible magnifique voix
de gagner déjà là bas c'est quand même
quelque chose toulouse est une belle
équipe de ligue 2 c'est parfait enfin
c'est un bel exploit je sais très bien
que il ya un peu l'actualité
footballistique sur versailles c'est
plus le rugby en général donc ça change
un petit peu c'est très bien je pense
pourquoi le fou de faire et aussi c car
les petits poucet c'est ça qui bat les
grands donc on espère qu'ils iront mois
on espère les voir en finale était
fait un jour un versailles barça 600 kg
prix des champions
versailles barça pourquoi pas
effectivement way en tout cas plus que
deux matchs avant la finale au stade de
france bergerac versailles mercredi 9
février coup d'envoi à 18h30 mais ce
sera à périgueux oui car le stade de
bergerac n'est pas homologué pour
recevoir une telle affiche la rencontre
se jouera donc à 50 km de bergerac dans
le stade francis rongiéras de périgueux
une antre de 6000 places assises 4000
debout occupée habituellement par le
club de rugby c'est là déjà que bergerac
zéro but encaissé en coupe de france il
faut le préciser c'est une belle
performance à éliminer saint-etienne
lors du tour précédent 8e de finale elle
a encore l'enceinte n'est pas homologué
mais dispose d'une dérogation de la
fédération française de football ce qui
est un peu agacé côté yvelinois privé
aussi de leur stade mont boron lors du
tour précédent car l'éclairage n'est pas
aux normes on rappelle cette règle
vieille des bâtiments de france on ne
peut pas voir de grosses sources
lumineuses depuis la chambre de louis
xiv du château de versailles alors les
versailles et par la voix de leur
directeur leur responsable de la
communication michael niche et militait
pour disputer la rencontre plutôt matmut
atlantique le stade des girondins de
bordeaux 42000 places qui était l'un des
sites est de l'euro 2016 ce à quoi le
président de bergerac a répondu sur
twitter christophe fauvel le matmut pour
accueillir les versaillais ça va les
chevilles du côté du château on l'a
compris la rencontre est déjà lancée à
falloir être à la hauteur c'est bien de
chambrer mais maintenant ça va jouer sur
le terrain avec les crampons et ouvert
suivra ça bien évidemment sur notre
antenne tout au long de la semaine
prochaine merci grégory on quitte le
sport pour l'instant on y reviendra tout
à l'heure avec les jeux olympiques
d'hiver et qui débute auparavant c'est
une autre actualité de cette semaine que
nous allons décrypter avec vous menez
[Musique]
mélanie cette semaine encore de nouveaux
labels on va appeler ça comme ça qu'ils
ont été décernés à des communes des
yvelines cité éducative cité de l'emploi
par exemple à quoi tout cela sert-il
vous allez nous l'expliqué elles ont un
point commun en tout cas elles
concernent les habitants des territoires
politique de la ville et oui on va
commencer que le premier ce sont les
sites éducatifs c'est le premier label
qui a été pensée par le ministère de la
cohésion des territoires neuf communes
des yvelines sont concernés 4,4 viennent
tout juste d'être labellisé c'est le cas
de limay où de plaisir alors ce label en
lien avec l'éducation nationale vise à
intensifier les prises en charge
éducative des enfants à partir de 3 ans
le début de la scolarisation et c'est
jusqu'à leurs 25 ans il faudra chercher
rechercher la mixité sociale et scolaire
renforcer le suivi personnalisé
développer la mobilité et les rencontres
etc il ya plusieurs critères les sites
éducatifs rassemble tous les acteurs
éducatifs les services de l'état les
collectivités les associations et bien
sûr les habitants donc il faut attendre
d'avoir eu ce label pour que ces
différents services se parlant services
de l'état collectivités associations et
habitat n'espère ce sera pas qu'une
coquille vide et qu'effectivement il y
aura des vrais échanges et des choses
qui vont en sortir il ya un autre label
aussi on l'évoquait tout à l'heure celui
de la jeunesse il ya une seule commune
du département qui est labellisé c'est
même un seul lieu pour le moment il
s'agit de la maison de la jeunesse et de
la réussite elle est à carrières sous
poissy c'est un lieu dédié cette fois
aux 16 25 ans qui vient de se voir doté
de deux cent mille euros sur deux ans le
projet regroupe là aussi dans un lieu
unique les services et les informations
dont un jeune peut avoir besoin pour ces
questions personnelles scolaire
professionnel mais aussi profiter de
moments de convivialité et je peux vous
dire avec la crise de la coved
apparemment les jeunes se ruent dans la
salle
une volonté d'inscrire cette cité de la
jeunesse dans les nouveaux dispositifs
vont être mis en place au 1er mars ura
le contrat d'engagement jeunes qui va
permettre à tous les jeunes de moins de
25 ans qui sortent des études d'avoir
pendant un an un soutien financier de
l'état pour s'insérer donc ça aussi
cette cité de la jeunesse devrait être
un lieu où on va signer des contrats
d'engagement jeunes voilà pour les
explications du préfet à l'égalité des
chances dans les yvelines qui était venu
donc sur ce plateau pour présenter un
petit peu ce dispositif y ait un autre
label inauguration également cette
semaine cité de l'emploi ça concerne
saint quentin en yvelines et 50 secondes
c'est l'une des cités de l'emploi en
adjei la ministre s'était déplacé à 50
ans l'une parce qu'elle a subie à une
convention cette fois ça concerne
l'ensemble des personnes de 16 à 60 ans
l'idée de regrouper là encore des
services cette fois de l'emploi autour
du monde notamment de l'entreprise mais
l'objectif c'est pas de mettre en place
une mesure c'est encore une fois de
mettre en place une méthode de
coordination de l'ensemble des acteurs
pour répondre à un problème que nous
connaissons maintenant depuis des années
mais des années c'est à dire le chômage
qui touche particulièrement les jeunes
alors là aussi c'est un accompagnement
de deux cent mille euros sur deux ans et
je lui disais tout à l'heure il y a
trois sites et de l'emploi dans le
département merci mélanie on espère
maintenant que ces labels ces
appellations de citer vous semble un
petit peu plus clair c'était notre page
décryptage du jour on va poursuivre ce
7,8 week end avec un autre décryptage on
va parler plutôt de politique chaque
semaine c'est l'équipe des surligneurs
qui réalise pour nous un légal chez king
sur l'une des déclarations des hommes
politiques et des déclarations il y en a
beaucoup en ce moment c'est un collectif
de l'université de versailles saint
quentin qui se venge donc aujourd'hui
sur la proposition de fabien roussel le
candidat communiste à la présidentielle
de créer un grand service public du
grand âge
réagissant aux scandales hors pair
fabien roussel candidat communiste à
l'élection présidentielle propose la
création d'un grand service public du
grand âge et que toute gestion d'un
ehpad soit à but non lucratif alors
outre les nationalisations juridiquement
acceptable mais financièrement très
coûteuse pour le budget de l'état
l'élimination progressive du secteur
privé soulève de nombreuses questions de
conformité au droit de l'union
européenne par exemple une première
solution serait la création d'une
structure administrative gérant tous les
ehpad sous un régime de service public
grâce à une tarification proche du coût
d'exploitation sans bénéfice donc ce qui
conduirait rapidement l essoufflement du
secteur privé toutefois l'union
européenne veille rigoureusement ce que
le secteur public ne mène pas une
concurrence déloyale vis-à-vis du
secteur privé une autre solution serait
l'arrêt des autorisations d'ouverture
d'établissements privés et le non
renouvellement de celles déjà en cours
ce qui aboutirait in fine et une
situation de monopole
président que les monopoles ne sont pas
interdit par le droit de l'union
européenne s'ils présentent un caractère
sanitaire et sociale comme c'est le cas
en effet des établissements très
médicalisé est destiné à des personnes
très dépendantes toutefois attention une
telle démarche serait juridiquement
périlleuse puisque la cour de luxembourg
n'autorise pas le monopole public dans
le secteur hospitalier
alors en vérité il est déjà possible
d'apporter des réponses juridiquement
viable à la situation comme intensifier
les inspections diligentées dans les
ehpad accroître le prononcé des
sanctions déjà prévues par la loi comme
la fermeture administrative des
établissements pour non-respect des
règles sanitaires ou encore appliquée et
rendre plus dissuasive les sanctions
financières par ailleurs des poursuites
pénales pour maltraitance aux personnes
vulnérables ou pour non dénonciation de
tels maltraitance sont déjà possibles et
enfin les salariés des ehpad à des
notions de tels maltraitance bénéficie
de la protection accordée aux lanceurs
d'alerté alors on le voit proposer des
mesures radicales sous le coup de
l'émotion n'est pas toujours pertinents
les outils juridiques existent et
peuvent tout de suite assurer une
qualité de vie digne dans tous les ehpad
il manque juste la conviction de les
appliquer
[Musique]
mathilde vous nous avez rejoint en
plateau bienvenus nous allons parler
loisirs avec vous dans quelques instants
grégory vous êtes resté aussi avec moi
puisque nous parlons aussi des jeux
olympiques avant la fin de cette édition
auparavant notre invité cette semaine
c'est michel barnier l'ancien candidat à
la primaire de la droite est aujourd'hui
conseiller spécial de valérie pécresse
il était en déplacement pour un meeting
dans les yvelines on les écoute au micro
de justin brasier c'est la première
réunion publique organisée dont les
yvelines depuis l'élection de valérie
pécresse au congrès les républicains
c'était en décembre dernier et ce 3
février nous sommes à la mairie du
vésinet pour suivre l'événement
événements qui se déroulent en votre
présence michel barnier bonsoir choix
ceux qui vous écoute merci vous est
conseillé france et europe donc dans le
monde auprès de valérie pécresse est
donc l'objectif c'est soutenir bien sûr
la candidate du parti elle l'est
républicain à la présidentielle mais
comment on va s'exprimer auprès des
yvelinois ce soir
comment je suis ici au vésinet à
l'invitation d'alexandra du blanche qui
est une de mes amis qui travaillent au
côté très très proche de pécresse qui
est une élue compétentes respecter
dynamique et d'objets très volontiers
que je lui ai apporté un peu de soutien
de confiance parce qu'elle va être
candidate pour être l'une des député des
yvelines au mois de juin prochain et
naturellement ensemble et avec tous
beaucoup d'élus parlementaires sénateurs
élus locaux et beaucoup de militants
nous sommes aux côtés de valérie
pécresse pour qu'elle devienne la
première femme présidente de la
république française ça sera notre
honneur et notre audace que de proposer
ce choix ou français et puis je vais ce
soir non pas faire de la propagande moi
je crois qu'une campagne électorale
c'est un moment de rencontre
confrontation de parfois de polémique
mais aussi un moment de pédagogie
d'écouté de dialogue de jouer comme je
suis aux côtés de valérie pécresse et ça
ne surprend personne en charge des
questions de politique étrangère
d'europe de sécurité extérieure parler
des des grands enjeux qui sont
importantes pour notre vie quotidienne
et qui nous concerne qu'il s'agisse du
changement climatique qui surgissent de
l'europe au moment où il ya risque de
conflits en ukraine qu'il s'agisse de la
sécurité de la lutte au terrorisme avec
ce qui se passe au au mali il ya
tellement de sujets qui qui sont des
enjeux globaux autour de nous dans le
monde tel qu'il est il faut bien
regarder les yeux ouverts et qui ont des
conséquences dans votre vie quotidienne
dont j'aurais dire un mot deux de ses
grands enjeux et dire la manière dont
valérie pécresse voler les engager un
échange donc auprès des yvelinois
d'ailleurs le département à les yvelines
un département largement de droite ce
sont les terres de valérie pécresse un
terrain qui est con qui selon vous a pas
d'élections gagnées d'avancé
y'a pas de conquête qui tombe du ciel
nous et valérie pécresse que chez bien
des vous regardez là l'opiniâtreté la
ténacité qu'elle met dans cette campagne
aujourd'hui je vous parlais était hier
soir sur le charles de gaulle en
méditerranée est en corse je serai avec
elle samedi elle elle fait une campagne
très sérieuse de respect et de dialogue
de respect de dialogue avec les citoyens
parce qu'il n'ya pas d'élections gagnées
d'avancé en tête du côté des sondages en
ce moment mais les piques à ses fans un
peu justement dans les sondages est ce
que vous seriez vous expliquer pourquoi
les sondages c'est une photographie à un
moment donné vous voyez bien que lé
pécresse dérange beaucoup elle dérange
le prêt public qui n'a pas envie d'avoir
une femme en face de lui au deuxième
tour et elle dérange monsieur et madame
le pen qui craignent d'être empêchés
d'être au deuxième tour donc on voit
bien les attaques se concentrent et
parfois violente parfois pas très digne
ou pas très correct néanmoins elle tient
sa route elle fait ses propositions une
par une jour après jour et elle résiste
on voit dans les sondages donc je pense
qu'à partir de cette base de confiance
qui est pas seulement celle des
républicains du centre c'est beaucoup
beaucoup d'électeurs je pense qu'elle va
monter au point d'être qualifié pour le
2e tour est très liée aux 2 au 2e tour
en tout cas aujourd'hui l'objectif c'est
vraiment d'échangé auprès enfin en tout
cas sur les grandes thématiques auprès
des événements moi je pense qu'il faut
respecter les citoyens faire appel à
l'intelligence c'est pas des slogans
dont ils ont besoin chacun des acteurs
c'est comment il a envie de voter mais
il vaut mieux que si on connaît bien à
la grèce parce qu'elle est d'ici mais je
crois que c'est important de savoir
qu'elle a une équipe constituée
d'ailleurs d'hommes et de femmes qui
étaient des opinions différentes au mois
de décembre moi même j'étais candidat à
la primaire on fait simplement ce qu'on
a dit on avait dit qu'on serait derrière
celle ou celui qui serait en tête et en
fait ce qu'on a dit donc voilà pourquoi
je suis content d'être avec elle quelles
sont les prochaines étapes clés est
finalement à venir dans cette course à
la présidentielle la campagne continue
c'est la fin d'une campagne très courte
que ton état nous pensons 10 avril donc
on a moins de deux mois donc c'est un
fois court et long pour aller dans tous
les départements y compris outre mer il
ya un grand meeting le 13 février à
paris au zénith où tout le monde est
invité et ça sera l'occasion pour les
pécresse de donner la confirmation de
cette dynamique est avec elle et de
présenter son programme donc voilà et
ensuite on enchaînera toutes les
réunions jusqu'au 10 avril et après pour
le deuxième tour aussi vous êtes vous
êtes plutôt ça va vous parlait déjà du
deuxième tour il pour vous donc on sera
au deuxième tour où et encore quand même
du travail à faire oui il ya toujours du
travail à faire mais on travaille pour
être avec valérie pécresse présent au
deuxième tour et offrir il s'agit de
cela une alternance une alternative
possible que ce duel annoncé fabriquer
davance par l'extrême droite le pen
zemmour ou par le présent sortant de
chez makro ce duel qu'ils veulent
d'entre eux comme si il était
propriétaire de ce deuxième tour eh bien
on vous demande que ça va pas se passer
comme ça mais que valérie pécresse porte
une proposition au nom de la droite
républicaine et du centre et beaucoup
d'autres électeurs pour le champ
différent de l'alternance moi je pense
qu'on a besoin d'une femme aujourd'hui
la place république on a besoin d'une
alternance il a écouté c'est sur ces
mots qu'on va à compass te laisser merci
beaucoup c'est le vernis d'avoir été
avec nous je rappelle un conseiller
français europe dans le monde auprès de
valérie pécresse est on le rappelle
prochaine échéance le 10 avril date du
premier tour des élections
présidentielles
merci donc à justine pour cet entretien
avec michel barnier le 7-8 week end
c'est aussi l'occasion de faire le grand
écart on va parler de sortir par les
loisirs à présent avec vous avec votre
sélection on commence par une rencontre
à ne pas manquer pour les fans du
palmashow grégoire ludig et julien
pestel seront présentes demain soir à
l'ugc de saint quentin en yvelines ils
présenteront leur nouveau film les
vedettes en avant-première à 20h30 six
ans après leur premier film la fois
l'histoire de max et leon le tandem
humoristique revient sur grand écran et
de quoi parle cette fois ci leur court
métrage aimant ce long métrage raconte
l'histoire d'un chanteur raté daniel qui
travaille dans un magasin
d'électroménager et qui est prêt à tout
pour rembourser ses dettes et se
retrouver sous le feu des projecteurs il
des ti il décide bardon d'utiliser
stéphane un collègue naïf et prétentieux
pour participer à des jeux télévisés on
regarde un extrait
envie de chanter oui mais non ça
j'arrête de
[Applaudissements]
chanter les gens qui sont seules ainsi
daniel qu'elle peut bravo les barricades
ok tout le monde on a un champion on
regarde les caméras sur lui
avant-première donc pour l'équipe du
palmashow grégory vous y serez will et
j'aurai la chance d'y être pour un
reportage en espérant pouvoir les
interviewer oui vous allez rencontrer et
les rencontrer et puis on verra tout ça
dans le journal de à lundi un petit
compte rendu voilà pour cet aperçu du
film date de sortie officielle mercredi
n'a faibli mercredi 9 février au par
rapport mardi maintenant autre idée de
sortie pour un escape game du côté du
château de monte-cristo effectivement le
célèbre château réouvre ses portes aux
fans des sketches game les participants
seront plongés en 1847 alexandre dumas
inaugure son château et de nombreuses
personnalités sont invitées pour
l'occasion parmi elles un homme qui
détient des documents confidentiels de
la plus haute importance menaçant la
sécurité de l'état leur mission sera de
retrouver en une heure top chrono ces
documents deux sessions sont organisées
le samedi et le dimanche à partir de 13
heures 45 et de 15 heures 45 attention
il vaut mieux réserver ses places à
l'avancé sur le site internet du château
le tarif est de 25 euros sites insolites
pour faire un nouvel escape game pour
découvrir tout cela ce week end une fois
le week-end passé on va se projeter
quelques jours après c'est la saint
valentin on manque toujours
d'inspiration vos conseils et j'en
profite et oui et pour les amoureux du
cou qui n'ont pas d'idées pour la
saint-valentin asmodée à trouver une
solution pour vous l'éditeur de jeux
lance un concours pour vous faire gagner
une box spécial saint valentin dedans
les plus chanceux pourront retrouver un
jeu de société pour jouer à deux mais
également un appareil à raclette deux
paires de chaussettes toute douce une
boîte de tisanes septième ciel et enfin
un kit de massage pour participer
remplissez le formulaire sur time to fly
box.com avant le 9 février le tirage au
sort aura lieu à cette date et les
coffrets seront envoyés aux gagnants
avant le 15 février mais on n'oublie pas
quand même les célibataires ils peuvent
également tenter leur chance bien
évidemment c'est tout aussi sympa de se
retrouver autour d'une raclette et dans
ton jeu société en train missions vont
profiter moi très vrillé parce qu'après
on arrive sur mars avril et le body se
meurt il faut faire attention la
raclette ça va pas le faire
dernière idée de de loisirs et de sortie
alors là ce sera pour vous permettre de
vous préparer un petit peu et
d'organiser dans votre planning à
l'avance c'est le week-end de gaming qui
est proposé à plaisir non pas ce
week-end mais week end après oui la
semaine prochaine la vie de plaisir l'un
son premier évènement 100% jeu vidéo
palais des sports pierre coubertin le
samedi 12 février donc les jeunes à
partir de 15 ans pourront se défier dans
des tournois de jeux vidéo de 10h à 22h
au programme quatre tournois sur fifa 22
super smash bros ultimate roquettes
league ou encore league of legends les
inscriptions sont ouvertes sur le site
internet de la mairie de plaisir
attention un même joueur ne peut pas
s'inscrire sur plusieurs tournois et
vous allez vous inscrire à jeunes
lequel
marion je suis 4e
qui forcément va forcément faire
transition toute trouvée on va parler de
sport comme ça pour terminer avec notre
dernière séquence de sept huit week-ends
séquence à suivre
et à suivre donc dès ce week end et tout
au long de la semaine prochaine les jeux
olympiques d'hiver vous allez la suivre
les suivre ces différentes compétitions
c'est toujours un événement que l'on
suit avec attention même si tout un tas
de polémiques diplomatique autour de ces
jeux olympiques contexte particulier
entre les questions écologiques et
environnement sûr sur sur place les
questions aussi de boycott avec les
questions de droits de l'homme notamment
voilà et puis les locaux vides la coved
finalement c'est aussi compliqué pour
suivre cette compétition et des stades
qui vont être désespérément vide en tout
cas moi je vais vous parler de 110 clair
elle a 33 ans et un nom qui vous dit
peut-être quelque chose car si elle est
née à toulon elle a longtemps résidé
dans les yvelines à plaisir plus
précisément elle s'est entraînée au
vélodrome national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines c'était une
pistarde vous ne voyez l'image palmarès
championne du monde chez les juniors dix
fois championne d'europe deux fois ci
les élites alors qu'elle vient avec les
jeux olympiques d'hiver me direz vous et
bien aujourd'hui c'est une beau buzz
savez ce qu'est une beau buzz elle fait
de bobsleigh voilà bravo elle s'est
reconvertie elle va participer donc aux
jo de pékin où il écoute quand je
faisais du vélo c'est mon frère qui
m'entrainait et en fait on délirait
france parti d'un délire où on disait
ben toi donc lui tu pilotera et puis moi
je pousserai et est en fait voilà j'ai
voulu vraiment tester ce que ça faisait
une descente de bob donc
j'ai contacté la pilote margot boc et
puis donc ça c'était pendant le
confinement donc emprunter en 2020 moi
c'était vraiment d'abord dans un but
c'était plaisir quoi vraiment découverte
et au final j'ai accroché tout de suite
c'est seulement la deuxième sportif de
l'histoire de djo pour les français à
participer aux deux olympiades été et
hiver pour l'aspect historique on
retiendra aussi donc c'est la première
fois que la france envoie des boobs donc
aux jeux olympiques depuis
l'introduction du bobsleigh féminin
c'était en 2002 2002 marveaux s et es ou
à salt lake city serait bien bien me
disais c'est bien prochaine question est
pour vous pour en revenir à sandie clair
c'est d'autant plus impressionnant que
s'il s'agit de noms reconversion est
clair un an et demi seulement après
avoir arrêté la piste elle est passée au
bobsleigh elle avait toutes les qualités
pour réussir on l'écoutait nouveau alors
les qualités physiques c'est les mêmes
parce qu'il faut être à la fois fort
rapide et donc puissant mais par contre
je passe d'un vélo donc un sport portée
ben c'est de la course à pied en fait
pour s'entraîner on fait de la
musculation et de l'athlétisme du sprint
et là par contre c'est enfin moi j'ai
jamais couru de ma vie il a fallu que
j'apprenne à courir
enfin savoir voilà bien pousser bien
monter le genou la pose du pied au sol
c'est plein de petits détails mais c'est
hyper technique la course c'est très
très technique donc c'était vraiment un
j'allais dire un pari un défi énorme
quoi je défis énormes qu'elle a relevé
ne s'entraîne plus dans les yvelines
c'était surtout pour le clin d'oeil n'y
a pas encore de pipe de boeck de piste
de bobsleigh aujourd'hui dans les
yvelines peut-être sur la colline des
longs cours à un moment mais maintenant
on le sait ce sera pour les jo d'été ya
tout de même un petit regret pour elle
elle ne sera pas un titulaire elle sera
remplaçante et tout cela pour
00 26 secondes c'est le temps qui la
séparait des titulaires lors d'un ultime
test au mois de janvier félicitations
elle et puis à bonne chance à la
délégation française voilà pour ceux à
7,8 week-end que nous allons refaire
mais merci au journaliste de tv à 60,18
merci aussi à vous de nous avoir suivi
lundi directes 18 heures pour le journal
en attendant vous pouvez nous suivre sur
les réseaux sociaux et consulter nos
replay sur notre site internet et
d'autres applications mobiles à très bon
week end
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]